Jessica Simpson's daughter rocks out to
Mom's throwback hit proving she might
just be Jess's biggest fan
the fashion Mogul was joined by her
hubby Eric Johnson and their three
kiddos Maxwell Ace and Birdie on her
latest style launch in Los Angeles Jess
and her crew posted up at the event and
fans were quick to notice that there's
more than one fashionista in the fam
Jess's 10 year old daughter Maxwell
rocked a cool grunge Girl inspired look
featuring an oversized camo print jacket
wide leg jeans and black platform boots
looking totally comfy in front of the
cameras our babies are beautiful and
when the LA Roller Girls perform to the
singer's 2006 track public Affair Max
was totally into it
[Music]
I am living for this mommy-daughter
dance moment I mean aren't kids supposed
to be embarrassed by their parents I am
celebrating nope not Maxwell she's
loving it singing and dancing full out
[Music]
and honestly this song is taking me back
to the early 2000s and I don't hate it
[Music]
as for the pre-teen she seems to love
the spotlight it's a circus back in 2018
she crashed her mama's interview with
E.T Hamming it up
that same year just told E.T that her
little girl is totally following in her
Showbiz footsteps has she been bugging
you to do it again
um she just does it every day to be
honest like I there's no stopping her I
don't I don't know what else to do it's
like out of my control what if your kids
came to you and said they want to be
performers that's what they want in
their career I would definitely embrace
my children being performers I mean to
me they're like the star of my life so I
I would love for the world to see what I
see Not only would Jessica support her
kids joining the biz she said she'd be
down to be their mama juror if you were
to manage them one day what kind of
momager would you be what kind of mom is
or would I be well I have the best
example in my mother my mom is never
like a stage mom she always was just
standing next to me encouraging me and
my parents never kept me from achieving
my dreams I mean I did it so young that
it's such a young age and they always
just say get up there you can do it if
you don't want to get up there you don't
have to
well we'll just have to wait and see if
Maxwell takes the stage one day but for
now we'll send you off with that epic
mommy daughter moment
[Music]